[Música]
el año 2002 científicos uno de ellos
premio nobel de química el otro un
biólogo muy destacado
paul crutzen y el yang y stormers
sugiriera a la comunidad científica de
que deberíamos cambiar el nombre de la
era geológica en la que vivimos ellos
decían ya no podemos seguirnos
denominando en la etapa del holoceno
tenemos que hablar del antropoceno
porque porque ellos veían a través de
los preocupantes datos que analizaban
que los seres humanos hemos adquirido
una fuerza tan grande que no son somos
inclusive comparadas ni siquiera
comparables a cualquier otra fuerza de
la naturaleza es decir nos hemos vuelto
más fuertes que un tsunami más fuertes
que un volcán más fuerte de cual que
cualquier otro fenómeno que el alcance
del impacto humano en el planeta es
global y que además también hemos
alterado el tiempo porque mientras los
ciclos de la tierra van de siglos a
milenios los ciclos que generamos los
seres humanos van de décadas a siglos
era realmente una un anuncio muy
alarmante que ha causado un revuelo
enorme en la comunidad de la ciencia y
que también ha transcendido a toda una
discusión interdisciplinaria ha
impactado en las ciencias sociales
las ciencias políticas en el ecologismo
inclusive en la filosofía y hasta en el
arte hay un diálogo muy interesante de
york que es una artista pop ustedes la
deben conocer con otro artista sobre
este tema y estas alertas que vienen
ahora de la ciencia han venido también
desde el siglo pasado de varias otras
comunidades de ambientalistas
movimientos feministas movimientos
ecologistas pero sobre todo de la
evidencia de que la base vital de la
vida en el planeta está siendo cada vez
medraba y cada vez a mayor velocidad
raquel carson que fue una de las
fundadoras de la ecología nos decía en
su libro la primavera silenciosa de que
estamos viviendo una tragedia porque
nosotros como seres humanos hemos
adquirido el gran poder de controlar la
naturaleza pero que al mismo tiempo
hacemos guerra contra el natural contra
la naturaleza y que esa guerra contra la
naturaleza es al final de cuentas y al
final del día también una guerra contra
nosotros mismos yo soy de la paz vivo en
una de las ciudades más hermosas
andes ubicada a 3.500 metros de altura
sobre el nivel del mar y rodeada de
hermosos glaciares este imán y es
nuestro apu es nuestro hacha chila es
nuestro guardián pero está perdiendo
cada año la nieve que lo cobijaba y que
era parte de nuestra identidad esa nieve
no solo es responsable de más o menos el
15 por ciento de el abastecimiento de
agua las redes de agua potable sino
también es sirve a las comunidades
aledañas que trabajan en agricultura
pero también guardan la memoria del
clima del planeta como todos los
glaciares los glaciólogos nos dicen que
pueden estudiar la historia del clima
del planeta a partir de igual que los
árboles sacando los diferentes estratos
de lo que ha sido la historia del clima
en el mundo entonces esa probablemente
es la metáfora más más triste más
dramática que nosotros vivimos al hablar
de estos cambios globales
estos cambios globales no solamente nos
están quitando la base vital sino
también nos están quitando lo que es
a lo que es la memoria
a pesar de las alertas a pesar de todas
las alarmas y rebeliones actualmente y
eso es lamentable traerlo acá pero que
es muy importante también decirlo
estamos viviendo la sexta extinción de
las especies animales y en el en el
planeta 85% de los animales salvajes se
han perdido en los últimos años las
cifras de las acumulaciones de gases de
efecto invernadero amenazan con llegar a
puntos de no retorno hacia mitades de
ciclo y con todos estos cambios por
supuesto lo estamos viviendo también se
aceleran y se intensifican las
catástrofes globales las catástrofes del
clima hemos visto lo que pasó con puerto
rico tres mil personas han fallecido
después del huracán maría que pasó hace
unos años por los tremendos incendios en
california que han destruido pueblos
enteros el último vórtice polar que ha
habido en eeuu y que y que ha llegado a
temperaturas más abajo de 50 grados bajo
cero es decir y en los andes' en los
andes' también estamos viviendo
la disrupción climática por la
alteración de la corriente del niño y
eso está trayendo todos los días
pérdidas territoriales y muertes
entonces cuando vemos todo esto esta
magnitud de destrucción decimos esto no
es una crisis ecológica esta es una
crisis de orden civilizatorio es una
crisis mucho mayor que está dando cuenta
de un fenómeno que nos atañe a todos
nosotros y es el fenómeno de la gran
ruptura que tenemos como seres humanos
como civilización con la naturaleza y
también da cuenta de esa gran ruptura
dentro del propio género humano en
particular la ruptura que ha habido
históricamente entre hombres y mujeres y
les voy a explicar más adelante porque
el tema del antropoceno como les dije
realmente ha provocado un gran debate
interdisciplinario y desde muchos lados
desde muchas muchas vertientes se están
debatiendo qué se puede hacer qué es lo
que cómo podemos seguir
hay un comité que se reúne anualmente
para determinar cuándo empezó el
antropoceno y esas son preguntas que
también nosotros nos podemos hacer
cuando realmente peso empezó cuando los
seres humanos se establecieron de ser
nómadas a ser agricultores a
establecerse en territorios con la
crianza de animales empezó tal vez con
el surgimiento del patriarcado que
implicó una ruptura enorme y fuertísimo
entre los géneros pero además que
implicó una construcción racional de la
ruptura con la naturaleza
tal vez empezó con la era moderna el uso
del carbón el uso del petróleo y toda
esa economía que gira alrededor de estos
combustibles contaminantes quizá con la
tercera ola con el siglo pasado después
de la gran aceleración que fue pactada
después de la guerra y que dio lugar el
incremento de un uso masivo del plástico
de la tecnología de obsolescencia
programada ustedes mismos tendrán en sus
casas algunos artículos todavía que han
sido fabricados tal vez antes de los
años 50 antes de los años 60 todavía
sirven pero los que han sido fabricados
después no duran mucho y hay que
descartarlos hay que descartarlos y
votarles y comprar uno nuevo eso fue
planificado eso fue pactado el plástico
en la compra rápida el uso del pollo
como base de la alimentación todos esos
elementos que forman que forman parte de
nuestro cotidiano son también parte de
esta este gran impacto que se ha
generado sobre el planeta pero quizás la
pregunta más importante es cómo va a
seguir nuestra vida
porque no estamos hablando de los
desafíos personales de corto plazo que
vamos a trascender o no vamos a
trascender estamos hablando de un
impacto global enorme entonces cómo va a
seguir nuestra vida esta situación este
nuevo diagnóstico este nuevo mapa nos
está indicando de que tenemos que
iniciar una profunda reflexión y un
profundo trabajo no solo de adaptación
sino de innovación y de innovación
social a gran escala y para ello es muy
importante este el pensamiento crítico
todos los pensadores todos quienes están
trabajando sobre este tema dicen que una
clave importante para responder a este
desafío de tal magnitud es desarrollar
el pensamiento crítico y hay una
escritora maria popova que decía que la
esperanza sin pensamiento crítico es
ingenuidad y el pensamiento crítico sin
esperanza es sí mismo tenemos que
encontrar el equilibrio
tenemos encontrar el equilibrio entre
realmente poder responder esta
información que viene que muchas veces
no queremos ver
y tenemos que aprender a superar el
miedo porque el miedo paraliza y no
permite procesos cognitivos complejos
porque esa es la dimensión que nosotros
necesitamos ahora desarrollar procesos
cognitivos complejos que nos permitan
enfrentar esta nueva etapa para mí el
antropoceno es como una especie de
nos han llevado a un mundo fronteras
un mundo fronteras en el que tanto
humanos como como especies animales
especies naturales estamos ubicados en
una franca de disrupción temporal de
disrupción y de conflicto pero al mismo
tiempo es un espacio de nuevos
aprendizajes es un espacio para aprender
y aplicar no solamente lo que conocemos
sino también imaginarnos y cambiar dejar
de pensar de la misma manera tenemos que
pensar de una manera diferente yo soy
activista e investigadora y trabajo con
varias comunidades de hombres de mujeres
de jóvenes que se han propuesto cambiar
el mundo que se han propuesto
transformar la sociedad y que algunos de
ellos sufren realmente situaciones de
conflictos sociales de explotación muy
fuerte muy conflictiva como las
trabajadoras del hogar que hasta hace
algunos años en nuestro país pero
todavía en algunos estratos vivían
situaciones de casi esclavitud o
personas que están ubicadas en
territorios donde hay conflictos de ccoo
sociales
y a pesar de esas situaciones complejas
estas personas son capaces de tener
esperanza y de tener el horizonte de
transformación social y aprendido con
ellas tres cosas básicamente uno que no
todo se puede cambiar que realmente
podemos fracasar en el intento pero que
nada va a cambiar si no lo enfrentamos
que lo más importante es enfrentar esa
situación el segundo tema que aprendido
con ellos es de que a pesar de toda esta
destrucción que realmente es
catastrófica los datos son alarmantes
existe una base social en todo el
planeta enorme de gente que está
sosteniendo la vida y que a partir de su
trabajo a partir de su actividad de su
relación con la naturaleza de esa
relación de reciprocidad esos contenidos
existen en nuestro mundo y nos dan una
base muy real muy objetiva de que se
puede cambiar y tercero que realmente
tenemos que atrevernos a mirar los
puntos ciegos y aquí es muy importante
adoptar las tecnologías de
transformación social que están en el
escenario yo trabajo por ejemplo con la
teoría o la teoría o es una teoría que
él ha propuesto tocarme en una
alemany que se propone o propone un
camino para la transformación social se
llama teoría porque nosotros cuando
estamos en un punto y queremos llegar a
un punto b
normalmente tratamos de hacer el camino
directo
la teoría ute propone precisamente hacer
la uv es decir si tienes una idea al
principio tienes que a veces dejar un
poquito ese te dije original y de
construir esos conceptos preconceptos en
colaboración con otros para llegar a
conectar con lo que es el entorno con lo
que es la naturaleza las fuerzas
sociales etcétera y luego empezar a
subir la uco creando y colaborando para
crear un modelo que esté alimentado de
esta complejidad los caminos fáciles ya
no son más posibles
entonces aquí es muy importante también
cambiar el paradigma de
si somos naturaleza o no la sociedad
la civilización humana sobre todo
occidental se basa en el concepto de que
la naturaleza está por fuera de nosotros
y ese es ese es el reconocimiento que
nos falta nosotros tenemos que
reconocernos como parte de la naturaleza
de hecho 70% de nuestro cuerpo es agua
casi todos nosotros somos todos nosotros
somos ecosistemas tenemos innumerables
organismos y bacterias que viven en
nuestro cuerpo entonces hacer una
transición del reconocimiento hacia la
naturaleza es más humano de lo que
parece y es muy importante encontrar ese
diálogo encontrar ese diálogo con la
naturaleza y no es poca cosa porque esto
también nos está indicando como en estas
rupturas que han habido a lo largo de la
civilización y esta construcción de
nociones y valores y principios y
filosofía detrás de la ruptura con la
naturaleza
es una construcción de mucho tiempo
francis bacon por ejemplo decía que hay
que torturar a la naturaleza hasta
extraerle todos sus secretos y ese es un
pensamiento muy instalado porque lo
consideramos consideramos la naturaleza
como algo fuera de nosotros como algo
que podemos que podemos alterar como
algo que podemos explotar y controlar y
ese paradigma se ha terminado ese
paradigma se ha roto el pensamiento
feminista la economía feminista
justamente retoma estas reflexiones y
estas visiones y nos propone un cambio
nos propone integrar en el nuevo mapa
3 al menos tres sectores uno de ellos es
el de la economía del cuidado es decir
de todo ese sector que nosotros no lo
vemos que no esté integrado en la
economía y que es ese trabajo de cuidado
que lo realizan sobre todo mujeres
estudios de varios organismos como la
cepal el bid el banco mundial la oit
indican que este trabajo podría llegar a
representar casi el 30 por ciento de la
riqueza mundial pero es invisible el
otro sector que se propone integrar es
el del trabajo voluntario aquí en este
auditorio hay muchas personas que he
escuchado que están trabajando de manera
voluntaria para resolver problemas para
atender emergencias para parchar algunas
heridas de nuestra propia sociedad pues
ese trabajo no es reconocido y tiene que
estar integrado dentro del sistema y
finalmente la naturaleza que es base
base de la vida y base de la sociedad
base de la civilización
al preparar esta charla pensaba en las
futuras generaciones las que van a tener
que vivir con el mundo que les estamos
dejando y realmente pensé que es lo que
les podemos dejar probablemente lo único
que nosotros les podemos dejar a
nuestros hijos a nuestros nietos es la
noción de la información crítica y el
optimismo ellos igual que nosotros van a
tener que lidiar con un mundo destruido
con un mundo en peligro con un mundo
ubicado en este mundo fronteras pero
tendrán también que apelar nuevamente a
los vínculos a los vínculos entre los
seres humanos a los vínculos con el
territorio a los vínculos con la
naturaleza a reconocernos en esa
naturaleza a reconciliarnos con ella
entonces transmitamos algo que dice
boris cyrulnik un gran etólogo y
psicólogo de la resiliencia el dolor es
inevitable el sufrimiento es una opción
eso no es necesario enfrentarlo podemos
construir sistemas y podemos construir
recursos y mecanismos a partir de
nuestras propias fuerzas maneras de
enfrentar esta situación que amenaza con
la vida en el planeta entonces la
alegría la esperanza y el pensamiento
crítico son aquellos elementos que
podemos dejar a las próximas
generaciones y sobre todo confiar en
ellos
[Música]